Shaft?
This the streets, son.
We gonna solve this
the Shaft way.
-I'm looking for...
-Shaft?
-Who's asking?
-John Shaft Jr.
-Junior?
-Yeah.
I'm here for business.
I need your help for a case.
I knew this day would come.
What's the case?
My best friend was murdered.
We got to go handle
our business.
Oh, no. See, I'm anti-gun.
He's running. Shoot him.
Where the guns?
Oh, I threw those
out the window.
You don't throw guns
out an open window!
Kids live up here!
If you're gonna pursue
this investigation,
I'm gonna have
to babysit your ass.
Yeah!
What are you doing?
The glass didn't break!
Get in here, JJ!
-Pop?
-Wait. Granddad?
You think I'll let you have
all the fun without me?
Please tell me
that you did not
get our son involved
in your bull--
That's Junior's mama.
She a little bitter.
Lady Syphilis,
Madam Chlamydia,
it's lovely to meet you both.
-You can't beat up a woman.
-Why not?
That's, like, misogynistic.
You the one
being misogynistic.
-I ain't mention her gender.
-Okay.
I'm an equal opportunity
ass-whooper.
Damn!
What was that?
It's capoeira.
Brazilian dance-fighting.
I was this far
from being proud of you.
Can you dig it?